nancy pelosi has a novel religious idea
she has a novel religious idea that one
can be a devout catholic
and support abortion it's an issue of
health
of many women in america especially
those
in a lower income situations and in
different states and it is something
that has been
a priority for many of us a long time
as a devout catholic and mother of five
in six years i feel that god blessed my
husband and me
with our beautiful family five children
six years almost to the day
but that may not be what we should it's
not up to me to
dictate that that's what other people
should do
and it's an issue of fairness and
justice for poor women in our country
so one it is up to you you're a
legislator you're the speaker of the
house it's up to you to make
the laws two you're saying pretty
ghastly thing that you
a nice rich lady should be able to have
a lot of kids but for poor people they
need to kill their kids so that they can
go work in the widget factory
or whatever but then to the religious
claim she says i'm a devout catholic but
i support abortion and the thing is
this is not just my opinion this is the
opinion of the catholic church
which we can know which is made public
you cannot be an abortion supporter
and a devout catholic at the same time
i'm going to you remember
in seventh or eighth grade you learned
about rules of logic
do you remember you learned the
contrapositive this is one of those
things people learn when they're a kid
and they forget
the contrapositive is this if if you
have if
p then q right
then if not q then not
p this your teacher wrote this on the
board when you were in middle school
so to give you a lesson on the
contrapositive on contraposition
if you are a devout catholic
then you do not support abortion
if you support abortion then you are not
a devout catholic
qed there you thank you for attending my
lecture
on contra position so now some people
have said michael how dare you you can't
judge people
i'm not judging her i'm i'm not damning
her or
sending her up to heaven i i don't have
the power to do that but i can
judge the teaching of the church because
the church is teaching us public
and what nancy pelosi is doing right
here is committing a public sin it's the
sin of scandal
she's also lying a private sitting would
be say if nancy pelosi goes home at
night and drinks three bottles of wine
and then i gossip around and i i could
start spreading these rumors or
something
or a private sin is she goes and cheats
on her husband or whatever
you see what she's committing is a
public sin and she's making a claim that
is demonstrably false
it is not possible to be a devout
catholic
if you support abortion i'm so
glad that you liked that clip i am
honored
i am pleased i'm flattered if you want
to watch the whole show go check it out
it's called helter skelter's here again
it is on youtube you can ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications
hopefully sometimes these guys don't
send the notifications out for our show
wonder why you can also get it at apple
podcast spotify google play stitcher
michael knowles show you can subscribe
leave a five star review and you can
also order the number one national
bestselling book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds check it out
and i'll see you next time